we're going to begin with steve harrigan
steve is live in atlanta
on the cdc's next steps what can you
tell us steve
arthel this was widely seen as the last
step before
distribution really the final hurdle the
cdc
advisory panel voting just about an hour
and a half ago to recommend that
americans
age 16 and over use the pfizer vaccine
that is safe
for use a number of medical experts have
said not only
is this pfizer vaccine a complete
breakthrough
but is also safe
we know a lot about this vaccine it's
been extensively tested in large
populations
it does require two doses it provides
stunning protection 95 percent that's
more than we anticipated
and the studies show that it's safe we
have
a little bit of a side issue here with
people who've had
serious allergic reactions in the past
that was just discovered in britain
we'll take care of that going forward
but we think we can
roll this out really in a very
deliberate careful way
first to healthcare workers and also to
residents of long-term care facilities
we're all looking forward to that
95 percent effective the pfizer vaccine
was developed
in just 11 months in a second vaccine
already on the very near horizon moderna
also a highly effective vaccine
scheduled to be approved next week
arthel back to you
very encouraging news steve harrigan
thank you